[Music]
I've introduced a few derivative
formulas but a really important one that
I left out was Exponential's so here I
want to talk about the derivatives of
functions like 2 to the X 7 to the X and
also to show why e to the X is arguably
the most important of the Exponential's
first of all to get an intuition let's
just focus on the function 2 to the X
and let's think of that input as a time
T maybe in days and the output 2 to the
T as a population size perhaps of a
particularly fertile band of Pi
creatures which doubles every single day
and actually instead of population size
which grows in discrete little jumps
with each new baby pi creature maybe
let's think of two to the T as the total
mass of the population I think that
better reflects the continuity of this
function don't you so for example at
time T equals zero the total mass is two
to the zero equals one for the mass of
one creature at T equals one day the
population has grown to two to the one
equals two creature masses at day T
equals two it's T squared or four and in
general it just keeps doubling every day
for the derivative we want DM DT the
rate at which this population mass is
growing thought of as a tiny change in
the mass divided by a tiny change in
time and let's start by thinking of the
rate of change over a full day say
between day three and day four while in
this case it grows from 8 to 16 so
that's 8 new creature masses added over
the course of one day and notice that
rate of growth equals the population
size at the start of the day between day
four and day five it grows from 16 to 32
so that's a rate of 16 new creature
masses per day which again equals the
population size at the start of the day
and in general this rate of growth over
a full day equals the population size at
the start of that day so it might be
tempting to say that this means the
derivative of 2 to the T equals itself
that the rate of change of this function
at a given time T is equal to well the
value of that function and this is
definitely in the right direction but
it's not quite correct what we're doing
here is making comparisons over a full
day considering the difference between 2
to the T plus 1 and 2 to the T but for
the derivative we need to ask what
happens for smaller and smaller changes
what's the growth over the course of a
tenth of a day a hundredth of a day one
one billionth of a day
this is why I had us think of the
function as representing population mass
since it makes sense to ask about a tiny
change in mass over a tiny fraction of a
day but it doesn't make as much sense to
ask about the tiny change in a discrete
population size per second
more abstractly for a tiny change in
time DT we want to understand the
difference between two to the T plus DT
and two to the T all divided by DT the
change in the function per unit time but
now we're looking very narrowly around a
given point in time rather than over the
course of a full day and here's the
thing I would love if there was some
very clear geometric picture that made
everything that's about to follow just
pop out some diagram or you could point
to one value and say see that part that
is the derivative of 2 to the T and if
you know of one please let me know and
while the goal here as with the rest of
the series is to maintain a playful
spirit of discovery the type of play
that follows will have more to do with
finding numerical patterns rather than
visual ones so start by just taking a
very close look at this term 2 to the T
plus DT a core property of Exponential's
is that you can break this up as 2 to
the T times 2 to the DT that really is
the most important property of exponents
if you add two values in that exponent
you can break up the output as a product
of some kind this is what lets you
relate additive ideas things like tiny
steps in time to multiplicative ideas
things like rates and ratios I mean just
look at what happens here after that
move we can factor out the term 2 to the
T which is now just multiplied by 2 to
the DT minus 1 all divided by DT and
remember the derivative of 2 to the T is
whatever this whole expression
approaches as DT approaches 0 and at
first glance that might seem like an
unimportant manipulation but a
tremendously important fact is that this
term on the right where all of the DT
stuff lives is completely separate from
the T term itself it doesn't depend on
the actual time where we started you can
go off to a calculator and plug in very
small values for DT here for example
maybe typing in to to the 0.001 minus 1
divided by 0.001
what you'll find is that for smaller and
smaller choices of DT this value
approaches a very specific number around
0.6931 don't worry if that number seems
mysterious the central point is that
this is some kind of constant unlike
derivatives of other functions all of
the stuff that depends on DT is separate
from the value of T itself so the
derivative of 2 to the T is just itself
but multiplied by some constant and that
should kind of make sense
because earlier it felt like the
derivative for 2 to the T should be
itself at least when we were looking at
changes over the course of a full day
and evidently the rate of change for
this function
over much smaller timescales is not
quite equal to itself but it's
proportional to itself with this very
peculiar proportionality constant of
0.6931
and there's not too much special about
the number two here if instead we had
dealt with the function three to the T
the exponential property would also have
led us to the conclusion that the
derivative of three to the T is
proportional to itself but this time it
would have had a proportionality
constant 1.0986 and four other bases to
your exponent you can have fun trying to
see what the various proportionality
constants are maybe seeing if you can
find a pattern in them for example if
you plug in 8 to the power of a very
tiny number minus 1 and divide by that
same tiny number what you'd find is that
the relevant proportionality constant is
around two point zero seven nine and
maybe just maybe you would notice that
this number happens to be exactly three
times the constant associated with the
base for 2 so these numbers certainly
aren't random there is some kind of
pattern but what is it what does to have
to do with the number 0.6931 and what is
eight have to do with the number two
point zero seven nine well a second
question that is ultimately going to
explain these mystery constants is
whether there's some base where that
proportionality constant is one where
the derivative of a to the power T is
not just proportional to itself but
actually equal to itself and there is
it's the special constant e around
2.71828 in fact it's not just that the
number e happens to show up here this is
in a sense what defines the number e if
you ask why does a of all numbers have
this property it's a little like asking
why does pi of all numbers happen to be
the ratio of the circumference of a
circle to its diameter this is at its
heart what defines this value all
exponential functions are proportional
to their own derivative but iya loan is
the special number so that that
proportionality constant is one meaning
e to the T actually equals its own
derivative one way to think of that is
that if you look at the graph of e to
the T it has the peculiar property that
the slope of a tangent line
to any point on this graph equals the
height of that point above the
horizontal axis the existence of a
function like this answers the question
of the mystery constants and it's
because it gives a different way to
think about functions that are
proportional to their own derivative the
key is to use the chain rule for example
what is the derivative of e to the 3t
well you take the derivative of the
outermost function which due to this
special nature of e is just itself and
then multiplied by the derivative of
that inner function 3t which is the
constant 3 or rather than just applying
a rule blindly you could take this
moment to practice the intuition for the
chain rule that I talked through last
video thinking about how a slight nudge
to T changes the value of 3t and how
that intermediate change nudges the
final value of e to the 3t
either way the point is e to the power
of some constant times T is equal to
that same constant times itself and from
here the question of those mystery
constants really just comes down to a
certain algebraic manipulation
the number two can also be written as e
to the natural log of two there's
nothing fancy here this is just the
definition of the natural log it asks
the question e to the what equals two so
the function two to the T is the same as
the function e to the power of the
natural log of 2 times T
and from what we just saw combining the
facts that e to the t's its own
derivative with the chain rule the
derivative of this function is
proportional to itself with a
proportionality constant equal to the
natural log of two and indeed if you go
plug in the natural log of two to a
calculator you'll find that it's 0.6931
the mystery constant that we ran into
earlier and the same goes for all of the
other bases the mystery proportionality
constant that pops up when taking
derivatives is just the natural log of
the base the answer to the question e to
the what equals that base
in fact throughout applications of
calculus you rarely see Exponential's
written as some base to a power T
instead you almost always write the
exponential as e to the power of some
constant times T it's all equivalent I
mean any function like 2 to the T or 3
to the T can also be written as e to
some constant times T
at the risk of staying over focused on
the symbols here I really want to
emphasize that there are many many ways
to write down any particular exponential
function and when you see something
written as e to some constant times T
that's a choice that we make to write it
that way and the number E is not
fundamental to that function itself what
is special about writing Exponential's
in terms of e like this is that it gives
that constant in the exponent a nice
readable meaning here let me show you
what I mean all sorts of natural
phenomena involve some rate of change
that's proportional to the thing that's
changing for example the rate of growth
of a population actually does tend to be
proportional to the size of the
population itself assuming there isn't
some limited resource slowing things
down and if you put a cup of hot water
in a cool room the rate at which the
water cools is proportional to the
difference in temperature between the
room and the water or set a little
differently the rate at which that
difference changes is proportional to
itself if you invest your money the rate
at which it grows is proportional to the
amount of money there at any time in all
of these cases where some variables rate
of change is proportional to itself the
function describing that variable over
time is going to look like some kind of
exponential and even though there are
lots of ways to write any exponential
function it's very natural to choose to
express these functions as e to the
power of some constant times T since
that constant carries a very natural
meaning it's the same as the
proportionality constant between the
size of the changing variable and the
rate of change
and as always I want to thank those who
have made the series possible
you
[Music]
you